[Laughter]
okay cool so how many of you do
oauth
at work
good good good and the other ones are
doing it as well because it's everywhere
these days really yeah so i've been um
i've been focusing on you know
authentication authorization
technologies for the last i don't know
15 years or so
and um
been focusing on oauth and body connect
for the last 10 years and you know when
you're doing that stuff for such a long
time
am i too loud by the way
okay
um
then you start to drill in more details
and more details and you're doing these
talks about these very specific things
and advanced topics and so on
um
but this year marks an interesting
turning point in oauth because there
will be the first ever revision
to the specification
after
10 years
yeah and this revision to the
specification you know we are all
developers i guess so you know semantic
versioning right where you just add
stuff and don't break existing stuff
it's just the other way around
it's reverse semantic versioning they
just removed stuff and didn't add
anything but that that is a good thing
because you know this technology has
been around
for over 10 years and some of that were
good ideas
back then and some of them didn't work
that well right so they decided that
this year
is going to be the time where they
look at the spec again and remove all
the things that you would not use
anymore today which means the spec is
well it's not getting smaller but
at least there's less to learn okay um
and it's called over 2.1 and that's
basically what i'm basically the plan
today is to just focus
on these useful things
okay
um
and
it's an introductory talk okay so if you
are an oauth expert you might be bored
yeah but that's the that's the exact
intention here it's it's starting from
scratch and trying to in 60 minutes give
you as much oauth as you need so to
speak yeah so don't complain afterwards
like oh that was too basic no that's the
intention okay i'm trying to be as basic
as possible
um
also which is probably one of my
favorite most favorite outcomes of this
talk is that people come to me and say
you know what
i thought i know oauth
but i was wrong
so you you know now now that you strip
away all the unnecessary stuff it's
easier to see the the trees in the wood
so to speak okay so that's kind of the
intention of that yeah
good my name is dominic um as i said i
work for this for way too long
and
also for the better half of my career
was working on an implementation of
oauth called identity server it's an
open source project
and you know
that means when you're implementing this
you have to read those specs more than
once typically so
i you know i i spend a lot of time
reading those specs and it's not
everybody's cup of tea i totally get
that right i mean it's using a career
font and that doesn't sound like fun
right all these rfcs and so on um
yeah so that's why i'm here and trying
to put it into
plain english as much as a german can i
guess
um
yeah so
just to give you some context yeah that
is the short history of web-based
authentication and authorization it all
started in 2005 with the mother of all
protocols called saml2p yeah and some of
the some of you might use that still
today
um and it was like the first ever
protocol that um
that invented this
uh request response style of
authentication where you have a browser
you send the browser somewhere then the
browser calls you back
right and then you process a response
you know that challenge response type
style
that was what saml 2p invented yeah and
everything that came afterwards is
basically just the same
right just using different technologies
so yeah that's dead then there was w
celebration w's trust you know like the
the dark times of xml i guess um
and then
and that that's very important to
understand yeah o of 1.0 in 2007 was a
direct count counter reaction to those
complicated xml based protocols they
want to be something simpler yeah so
they they started reimagining this and
focusing more on on specific um use
cases and maybe too specific because
shortly after they added over 2.0 which
added more use cases again yeah and
people talk about this
and then as you can see
there are a whole bunch of additional
specifications that happened between
2012 and today
okay and these are the ones we are not
going to talk about yeah because they
are just you know they are a distraction
for now
um but here
this is the the o of 2.1 um
um that i mentioned earlier so that is
going to be the ever first update to the
original spec um to make it more
modern i guess
okay cool
so that's kind of like the big picture
and of course
this gave me finally the chance to do a
talk that that is called the good parts
right
um we probably all know this book right
javascript the good parts where the left
one is all of javascript and the right
one is the the good parts
um
so i'm all about here teaching you the
good parts
and then once you appreciate a good part
obviously
it makes sense to know some of the bad
parts as well and why you should avoid
them yeah but again that's not our topic
we could be we we're gonna do the happy
path
okay
good
so
the agenda is this so uh first of all
why does off exist right and then we're
going to talk about what they call
protocol flows and there are really two
left so oauth started with five
different flows or protocol flows in the
original spec and there are two left of
them which means the other three
don't care anymore that doesn't matter
yeah um
then we're going to talk about typical
applications you would build with these
flows
and then um maybe you've heard over and
over for example guys like me saying
oauth is not authentication and we're
going to have a talk talk about why
ma'am
and then i'll give you some more
more pointers to further reading um
literature if if you want to dig deeper
into the topic
cool so
why does oauth exist right as i said
earlier
oauth was a direct
reaction to the
enterprise-y world of the beginning of
2000 right xml and soap and namespaces
and all of that complicated stuff
and google basically said hey um
we're building these consumer-facing
apis and we have a very simple problem
to solve how can a third party how can
you give a third-party access to your
google calendar without you having to
expose your password to the first to the
third party
right they obviously didn't want that
you type in your google password into a
third-party service they wanted
something else right something that
allows you to grant someone access to to
as to data or even a subset of your data
without exposing your master secret so
to speak right and um obviously this was
all based on um we we we don't call them
web services anymore right because
that's xml and that's that's evil yeah
they call them apis or web apis or http
apis you know whatever we're going to
call them yeah um
but it turned out this whole xml
soap
thermal era
invented one
really good
concept
which are
tokens
okay so instead of sending your password
to
a service you are sending a token to a
service and that token represents
access to some data or a subset of data
for a limited amount of time
without having to expose your password
okay
so that was a good thing um but it was
xml right i mean they looked like this
and you probably all remember that right
where you basically have
uh
95 percent headers
and a little bit of payload
right um
but it turns out um
the
ideas in that they were good right
because they had they introduced the
concept of issuers and signatures
meaning who created the token do i trust
this person and to technically enforce
that trust it was digitally signed so we
can validate the signature if the
signature validation succeeds we know
it's coming from a trusted issuer
google for example or whoever right um
it had another
interesting concept called the time
window right
as a
in contrast to your password which was a
long term secret yeah these tokens could
be short-lived could be valid for one
hour for one day for one week whatever
makes sense for your for your business
case
um it had the concept of scoping you
know again contrasting it to your
password your google password gives
anyone access to everything you own in
google but a token can be scoped to just
for just the calendar api for just the
gmail api for just the the drive api or
even saying uh email read permissions
but not right right these things so
that's a concept coming from xaml tokens
um
the concept of putting authentication
context information into into tokens
like who is the user how did he
authenticate is it strong enough for us
things like that yeah came from here
uh and ultimately claims so
if you live in a microsoft space you
might think microsoft invented claims
they did not
yeah they just reused the concept coming
from the saml working group basically
give you a key key value pair style of
expressing identity information about
the user yeah and again this was all
very convoluted right they had like xml
name spaces and all of that and we
wanted to make that simpler man
and the main problem with this with this
technology otherwise maybe we we would
still have it was
that it didn't work
and and what i mean with it didn't work
is it did not work with the requirements
of a consumer style world right so we
might have been lucky to make two wcf
services talk to each other right but
have you ever tried making a wcf service
talk to the thing from sun or the thing
from someone else right i mean you first
have to find an xml parser that
understands both dialects right so this
was not going anywhere they they wanted
a basically an easy way bring up some
developer documentation
here's how you call our api it's json
based right you make a post request send
us this data attach this token it should
work without having a phd in angle
brackets
right
so
that is um
the one requirement that it basically
was all designed for third-party
consumption
right whereas all of the enterprises
stuff was mostly optimized for first
party consumption right you are
accessing your own services because
we're using the same technology stack on
client and on the server
the other thing was the enterprise did
not care about humans right
i mean you were an employee of a company
you you log into your ad account you
access ad company resources um no one
asked you like do you want this
application to access your calendar
right i mean they were all owned by the
company whereas in the consumer space
right this is not true the the third
party application that might wants to
add value to your calendar is not
written by google
right um so google
very much had an interest of saying hey
are you okay with granting
third party x access to your calendar
and put the human into the picture and
that is called a consent screen i'm sure
you all have seen that before right do
you want to expose your email address
and most people just blindly click yes
because no
i don't know what no does
um
so these were requirements okay and they
did not work with the xml soap soapy
style
stuff we had before right and that's
that that were all
um
motivations for
creating oauth ma'am
so how does
what's o off right so basically the idea
is very simple yeah um and and i'm
deliberately using the terms from the
spec so that when you go back to the
talk with a recording and you want to
read the spec you find the same terms
they are not
very commonly used in normal language
today right but the idea of oauth was
basically you had
resources
a calendar an inbox right whatever and
these resources are running on a
resource server which we now today call
apis typically okay
and then alongside of that resource
server you have another thing called the
authorization server and that is the
thing that can determine if someone is
allowed to access your resources
okay and that is also the thing that
will create these tokens that then the
client application can use to consume
those services
okay and they are always together yeah
so the assumption is that the the
resource server and the authorization
are always owned by the same entity
right the the the company that exposes
the resources has a resource server
either their own or as a service
whatever but they belong together
um and and trust each other that's the
important part here yeah
then we have clients okay the clients
are the applications that want to access
the resources
yeah
there are different types of clients
right there are
ultimately there are
clients running in the browser and
clients running outside of the browser
that's basically all we have right
um most of them run in the browser
like web applications you know spas
things like that we have mobile
applications which maybe use the browser
for authentication but the main app is
native right and we have classic
server-to-server style communication
man
some of these clients are considered to
be confidential and they are basically
boiling down to things that run on a
server
right so someone installs them you give
them a client id and the client secret
so they can authenticate with you these
this the secret is stored securely on a
server maybe on something that you own
or maybe on a business partner server or
whatever right
whereas the the so-called public client
are the ones that you can't control like
mobile devices or a javascript
application they run outside of your
control and they are considered less
uh less confidential than the ones
running on on server hardware right also
less exposed to attacks and and all
these things
some of these clients
have users
okay and uh the over spec calls them
resource owners and what they mean is
that they own some data on the resource
server but i think that is a very
misleading term we call them users these
days typically okay and there you see
that there's a very important
distinction between users and clients so
users are human beings okay carbon based
life forms in in in your system yeah
they have some sort of account with you
and they have some sort of data that is
stored with you okay and these humans
want to use an application to access the
data right and these are the clients
some clients might be coming from you
first party clients some part some
clients might be coming from a third
party you know if you have a public api
there might be clients out there that
you don't even know about right someone
wrote them because you want them to
write those clients to access your apis
and you know have a business model
behind that
so that's that
and then regardless
how you
um access the system it's always the
same first of all the client needs to
make a round trip to the authorization
server and ask for a token
right uh it's called the authorized
request very often
i want to get authorized to access a
resource
and then if all is good
then the authorization level returns
that token and from that point on
the client is using the access token to
access the apis and again access tokens
have all of these good things right they
might they might be limited to a subset
of the apis they might have a limited
time window you might even revoke them
and so on right so all of the good
things that tokens can can give us as
opposed to shared secret style security
with passwords
good so that's that
and that's how it always works we could
stop here that's how it works
let's have a look at one very important
concept in oauth yeah which which they
call the scope
yeah and the scope is very very
loosely defined but the idea is is that
um in your system right these resources
here you give them logical names right
like calendar api or
email api whatever right and then you
basically can configure which client is
allowed to access which resource and the
parameter on the protocol that expresses
the the thing you want to access is
called the scope parameter yeah and as
you can see and that's typical of style
uh is it's just a string
um if you can have more than one value
on it and if that's the case it is space
delimited
and typically the assumption is is the
more strings you have on that parameter
the more access you have to the system
right calendar would be one
inbox might be another but you also
might say calendar and inbox because you
are a client application that needs to
access both
yeah which
is just the way it's done these days
um
but let me just give you some examples
of how
certain apis implement the scope
concepts so that's from the
from the github developer documentation
right so basically what the
their view of the world is we have this
one github api or resource server if you
like in the in the oauth speak and it
has
certain types of functionality right
there's access to repos access to user
information access to packages right and
then you your client basically needs to
when when it does the authorized request
needs to say hey please give me access
to repo and to read packages
okay
um and sometimes as i said
um they also need to go a little bit
fine trainer right maybe maybe it makes
sense to to split it up into right
packages and read packages maybe on your
ci server the token you have there the
client only needs to read from the
package feed but there's no point in
giving giving them right access to it
right that's how you can scope it down i
guess that's where the name comes from
yeah
um
also funny to see right software evolves
underscores colons and so on so it's you
know it's been evolving for i guess 10
years or so
that is how github is doing it
uh in contrast that's how google is
doing it for example yeah coming back to
google um
you know that i guess the fundamental
difference here is is that github is a
much much smaller company than google
okay but they have one product it's
github right you probably can you know
probably at some point every github
developer knew each other because they
met at a christmas party or something
but github is a huge company right i i
don't even know how many people work
there but so and they have many
you know independent products right
there's the the query api and there's
the calendar api that's the gmail api
and there's some cloud stuff and so on
right so um
you can imagine that um that there must
be some sort of governance model around
this yeah and you can you can imagine
that there is one guy at google who owns
these namespaces here right so
google made the decision to use urls to
represent scopes yeah it doesn't matter
what you're doing they're just strings
right github used colons
as a delimiter they use forward slashes
okay but the idea is again
that in their case
uh someone i guess will assign you a
namespace and then underneath that every
team probably can decide on their own
naming
that's a guess at least there
my point is um
um this the oauth itself does not give
you any guidance or any advice how you
should do that that is a complete you
know
uh
organization decision how you want to
structure your api surface and that
that's a good that's a good example for
a big api service yeah whereas github is
a little bit smaller
cool so that's one of the most confusing
things that people ask me about like
what's the scope
why do i need it
why doesn't the stack tell me exactly
what it is
yeah because they didn't know 10 years
ago right they just said like hear
something use it have fun
good now
i mentioned earlier that the original
spec had a couple of different what they
call protocol flows um
and what they mean with the flow is that
how a specific type of application
um can can talk to the authorization
server basically yeah and
ten years later we found out that we
only really need two of them because
uh it all boils down to we are we are
writing two types of applications these
days
non-interactive applications like server
to server batch processing message
queueing and interactive applications
which is everything else that has a user
in front of it in the browser in a on a
mobile device whatever so in overwatch
2.1 they boiled it down to exactly that
here's how non-interactive flows work
and here's how interactive ones work and
everything else is a distraction
okay
so let's start with the simpler one
which is machine-to-machine
communication right no user is present
just two machines talking to each other
but still you know the api that the
client calls
needs authentication somehow yeah and
it's really really simple
let me show you how it works
so here's our client right which might
be a server side process whatever here
are our resources api 1 api 2 api 3 and
so on and here's the authorization
server
now
one requirement in oauth is that the
client is
pre-registered with the authorization
server right so
an authorization that does not hand out
tokens to arbitrary unknown clients yeah
so that there's typically a registration
process happening first it might be an
admin thing might be a self-service
website where you register your client
whatever right so
at the end of the day
the client will get issued from the
authorization server a client id that's
how you uniquely identify the client and
a client secret that allows them to
authenticate the client to the
authorization server
so and then when when this client wants
to have a token it basically makes a
round trip to the authorization server
says hey
please give me access to api one
okay
in this case the client id and secret is
encoded on the authorization header
using basic authentication there are
many other ways of doing it like with
certificates and public private key
pairs and and so on that doesn't matter
really um point is the client
authenticate with the authorization
server asks for access to an api and now
the authorization server and that's
where the name is coming from
checks if that client is actually
allowed to access the api right again
there's some configuration on the server
that way somebody determined okay this
guy is allowed to access this
good and if all is good
it will basically return you
a response with a with a json body
with a thing called an access token
and that thing here the access token is
now what the client will use to call the
api
now how does an access token look like
that's another confusing thing in oauth
they didn't tell you right they said
you're going to issue an access token
um
these days yeah today it is very very
common that access tokens are in a json
depth token format right so the chase
and that tokens are really just is
really just a way to um
cryptographically secure a json object
right with a signature basically and for
making that work you need some metadata
like which key was used and which
algorithm was used to sign the json
object and this json object encapsulates
the authorization decision
of the authorization server
yeah it says okay
here's a client called client1 and i
gave him access to api one
okay and here's my signature to prove
that i am the right person that did that
make made this decision
yeah
and
the client receives that
thing which looks like this on the wire
yeah it's encoded in base64 url
and then we'll use that
um
to call the api now guess what
all of the useful things we had in saml
tokens are still there because they are
required yeah it just looks simpler
right
but it's you know
uh we still have the concept of an
issuer and a signature right the
signature is here and it points to some
key material at the trusted issuer the
issuer name is here as well there's a
time window issue iat means issued add
and exp means expiration that's the time
window in which this token will be valid
and after that it's not yeah
scoping is still there right here's our
scope parameter and claims are also
there and in this case it's a special
claim called client underscore id which
tells the recipient of the token who is
calling me
ma'am
cool and then ultimately the client will
call the api by making a call to the
resource and putting that token on the
authorization header
okay that there's a special thing called
coming from over called bearer and what
bearer means is basically you are
receiving an o of token and then what
the api will do it will receive the
token read it validate the signature and
once the signature is valid it can trust
the values inside the payload and then
it says okay
um
i am api one this token is for api one
all is good
okay maybe they want to do an additional
authorization on the client id or
whatever other custom data you want to
add but that's in a nutshell how it
works okay
so this talk is not really about code
boom
[Laughter]
this talk is not really about code but
if you are interested in how that would
look like in c sharp
that's how it looks like
okay you're creating a form
a form you're putting in all the
parameters grand type scope client id
and so on and you're sending that to the
token endpoint
of the
authorization server right and what
you're getting back is the the json
object i just mentioned which has the
access token in it
okay and there are client libraries of
course which make that much nicer and
easier and
i wrote one which is pretty popular as
well called identity model which
basically shields you from all of this
and you just say give me a token my
client id is this my client is dead and
here's the scope yes
yeah i'm i'm done with code
bang flight mode
okay it's it this talk is not about code
i just want you know if if somebody
needs to see that for a moment in c
sharp even if it's dark
that was the purpose of that okay
good
so
now
very important and a very
a source of confusion is um
there are some rules about access tokens
the first rule is and it's the most
important one that you should always
remember
the client application is not allowed to
touch it
okay the client should not make any
assumptions what's inside of that token
the token format and the token contents
are a private implementation detail
between the authorization server and the
resource server
right the client is just a forwarder of
that token yeah and you know i have
customers like yeah but it's a json web
token can i just look at it and get the
stuff i want
sure you can but if the authorization
server ever changes the format your
client will be broken
right so don't do it yeah
access tokens are purely
to be consumed by the api
and then there are some other boring
rules right you need to validate the
signature you need to check the issuer
name and that's all happening
at the at
the receiver and in the api okay but
from a client point of view
you just get this string from the server
and you forward it to the api and that's
what you're supposed to do
and if you are an api offer then you
typically never do this yourself that
there's libraries for that right in in
asp.net core that's the chat bearer
authentication handler you just tell him
where where is my issuer living and it
will auto configure itself validate
signatures do all of the time window
checking and so on and so forth right um
so that's these days it's pretty simple
two things um i also get a lot of
questions about is
what about status codes so you call the
api
yeah if everything is fine you probably
get back at 200 with some data right but
there are these these two edge cases
well i wouldn't call them edge cases um
whereas
not everything is fine okay
and that is basically the 401 has a
special meaning here for one
unauthorized and what the 401 means is
basically you are trying to access a
resource that requires a token but your
token is not valid
okay
might be missing might be coming from a
non
from a different issue that we trust or
the most common
reason it's expired
right tokens have a limited lifetime
um you should not
um
write your application in a way that it
depends on the lifetime of the token
because again the authorization server
can change any time the lifetime of your
token your application should always be
written in a way that it can deal with
expired tokens at any point in time and
when you when you get back a 401 99
percent of the times that means your
token has expired get a new one
okay
the other
status code you are interested in is
called 403 forbidden and what that means
is your token is totally fine but the
thing you are trying to access does not
give you access
right some sort of authorization
decision made by this by the api
in that case
it it is not worthwhile getting a new
token and trying it again right because
this probably won't fix your problem
yeah so
um this is very important when you're
writing a client application yeah so 403
basically means i can't do anything
about this right i mean i have to
surface this error to someone who can
fix this whereas 401 means let me get a
new token and retry
right that will probably fix the problem
if it doesn't fix the problem again
something is
out of sync in your system yeah but as i
said 401 typically means i need to get a
new token
good
and that helps you with token management
yeah so every client application out
there must somehow manage their tokens
right so you don't want to get a new
token for every api call that would not
be the most efficient implementation so
what you typically want to do is you get
a token keep it in memory or in a cache
or in a database and use it
typically until you get a 401 which
means it's expired then you get a new
one cache that again and start over
yeah that's the the typical
implementation of that
and you know in.net you can nicely
abstract that away with
http message handlers an hp client that
just gets the token if before one gets
returned get a new token under covers
try it again and if it's still a 401
well i can't do anything otherwise it
probably works
no
good
so
let's do it
if there are any questions let's put
them at the end i guess um just an
interest of time um that i'm getting
through the content
but that's all you need to know about
non-interactive applications right a
server talking to another server to make
that work you get an access token and
you use the token until it it's not good
anymore then you get a new one that's it
the much more interesting types of
applications because they're more
complex are interactive applications
right and that is where a human being a
user is using the application
interactively right
um and this is of course always more
complicated because well we involve
human beings that makes things always
more complicated yeah
um but also you have to coordinate more
things typically you want to coordinate
things like user authentication
single sign-on maybe joining some
sessions or you know doing some session
lifetime management and so on and that's
where
this approach here comes in which is a
little bit different yeah
so
there's a special flow in oauth called
the authorization code flow and that is
specifically designed to deal with
interactive applications
and
in particular to be able to during the
authorization process of getting a token
be able to show a ui
right because humans like uis
so um
in the server to server case there are
no ui is necessary there are two
machines they don't need a ui but if you
are running the application
um in front of a human you need that so
that's why
in oauth the authorization code flow is
split up into two logical steps the
first step is what we call the front
channel
and the front channel is everything
happening in the browser so it's
basically something that shows
uis to humans
login page content page whatever
whatever ui is necessary to complete the
token request yeah
and then
this is very important we um we don't
want to return that access token via the
browser back
to the client application because we
don't trust the browser right i mean
browsers are great yeah they have a very
nice feature that you can give them a
url and they just follow it right the
browsers are very dangerous as well
because you can give them a url and they
just follow it
so we want to
reduce the exposure of sensitive data in
the browser and in off case that is the
access token okay so what the front
channel will return is not the token
directly it returns something called um
a code and that code can then be used in
the second indirection by by doing a
server to server call to actually
retrieve the actual token
okay so let's have a closer look at that
so how does the front channel request
look like basically it's it's a redirect
okay to the authorized endpoint you put
a bunch of parameters there client id
redirect uri response type is code scope
right api one that's what we want to
access and now
a whole bunch of stuff kicks off in the
browser right probably the first thing
you see is is a login
right if you are not inside of an
existing single sign-on session you will
you will see a login screen you log in
somehow name and password whatever right
that login screen is running on the
authorization server meaning it's
running on the same entity that is
owning the resources right that's why
it's trusted
um
i mentioned the consent screen earlier
right that's how a consent screen could
look like and the whole idea is is to
involve the human by giving the human a
lot of information
like who am i who who do i think you are
who is who do i think the client is what
is the client asking for do you want to
allow this
right um
some companies like google and facebook
and so on they show them all the time um
they often they can make a distinction
between first party and third-party
clients right so where a third-party
google client will show the screen or
they show it for them so to speak there
is that the gmail app doesn't show it
right so that's how they express like
their level of trust i guess um and you
know you should read what's on there
yeah and it's hard to to create a good a
good content screen that a normal human
being who is not an oauth expert can
appreciate yeah
but yeah ultimately 99 of the time
people will click this
and when that happens
we get back
from the authorization server back to
the client application and redirect with
this thing called a code okay the code
is just a random string it it it means
nothing so to speak but this code
associates on the authorization server
side uh with the data that happened
during the front channel in direction
right who is the user did they consent
what are the resources they consented to
whatever right um but
what we are returning here is just this
random string and the idea behind that
is is that if an attacker would be able
to steal that random string they cannot
do anything with that
because it's not usable data to make
that data usable
on the back channel communication the
client opens a channel to the token
endpoint and authenticates again with
client id in secret and passes along the
code
right and only and there are many many
checks happening now like is the client
id valid is the client secret valid is
the client id the same as the one on the
front channel or all of these things
that should happen right
and if all of that is good
ultimately
the server will return the access token
and a so-called refresh token on on the
back channel communication and then the
client stores that data server side and
then they can access the apis
okay
so that's how it always works yeah and
it's a little bit confusing to start
with but imagine front channel is all
about ui and back channel is all about
now
turning the outcome of the ui into
tokens
good so how do user-centric access
tokens look like well they are pretty
much the same but as one important
addition here that it typically also has
an identifier for the user that
authenticated during the token request
right because now you want to be able to
call an api and that api must know who
the user is right because they want to
do authorization
yeah
so
um
in other words that there were two steps
of authorization happening at the tokens
at the authorization server level they
determine does client one have access to
api one that's the first thing okay and
then once that token reaches the api
typically the api will do authorization
decisions based on who is the user right
compared to a twitter client right uh
the twitter client connects to twitter
and it asks for permission to write to
the timeline
right that would be the scope yeah right
timeline but then when the twitter
client is actually writing to the
timeline they must include for which
user because you can't write to
arbitrary timelines right only the one
of the user that has authenticated with
okay so it's a two-step process
and that is sometimes a little bit
confusing what is the job of the
authorization server only the upper part
only determining if the client is
allowed to access the api anything else
beyond that is business logic in the api
itself
good
again token management
is more interesting here
because you know your your access token
might be valid for an hour
yeah but the application the user is
using might run for five hours or five
weeks or five years
right um so how what do we do
if the access token is expired we need a
new one but in the interactive flow we
saw we need to involve this front
channel thing right like go to the login
page and all of that and that would be a
very bad user experience right you're in
the middle of typing something suddenly
the browser makes a redirect to a login
page and comes back your form is gone
that would suck yeah
so
there's another thing here and another
technique that is always used for this
type of application called the refresh
token and the refresh token is it's just
another token that allows you to get a
new access token you think of sliding
cookies in the browser right in the
browser um that happens automatically in
oauth you need to make that
programmatically meaning once your
access token has expired you take the
refresh token go back to the token
server get a new access token and start
using that until that one is expired and
the whole thing starts over and over and
over again yeah
so how does that work well let's say um
our access token has expired then the
client application will
go back to the token server to the
authorization server it will basically
hand the refresh token in authenticate
with the authorization server and if all
is good you will get back a new pair of
access and refresh tokens that you can
use for the next time
okay
why are they doing it so complicated why
don't they just issue an access token
that lives for one year wouldn't that be
much simpler
well for security reasons right because
if that x token is leaking
and attackers stole it right they would
they would have access for one year to
your data and that's what we want to
avoid right um access tokens should be
short-lived in this case it's one hour
and after that one hour the client has
to go back to the authorization server
proof again that he's the right client
to get back a new access token for
another hour
right and the nice thing we can do with
this mechanism is well we can actually
revoke refresh tokens
right so many um
systems have that feature that's the one
from google they don't call it revoking
a refresh token they just say here are
apps
connected to your account and then you
can delete the app from here and what
that technically does it deletes the
refresh token so the next time this
client comes along and tries to hand in
the refresh token it will say no
you don't have access anymore okay so in
other words um
the lifetime of the access token
determines how quickly you can kick out
a client out of your system right so if
the access token is valid for one hour
and you delete the refresh token right
at the start it will take one hour
before that kicks in if you make the x
token five minutes it will only take
five minutes right and it depends again
what type of application you're building
what is the right value for you
right maybe banking applications health
care and so on they have better you know
stricter requirements than a restaurant
rating app
right
um
so that's an example of a self-service
revocation style but also of specifies a
programmatic revocation endpoint so
a well-behaved application that has a
refresh token for a user
um should
once they are done with the user and say
like i you know the user locked out i
don't need access anymore they should
revoke the refresh token
programmatically
right that would be good developer
hygiene i guess by just going here say
hey here's a refresh token i got from
you please invalidate it revoke it okay
so that in any case whatever happens
this thing will be not usable anymore
and also you help your authorization
server to keep your database smaller
right by not having to keep all of that
data that is stale yeah
good
so
um
that is basically the two building
blocks of oauth machine to machine and
indirective right and now you can build
a bunch of applications with that yeah
of course the easiest one would be
machine to machine right two machines
talk to each other
the all the other examples of all of the
other application types are basically
things like web applications right spas
web assembly applications mobile
applications desktop applications
anything you can imagine that has a user
interacting with
okay and as i said the way i have that
in my mind is it's either browser-based
or not browser-based now that's
basically the things we build these days
yeah
so
when we have a look at the typical
browser-based application technology
stack and let's let's use asp.net core
as an example because that's what i'm
doing all the time um it always looks
very similar right you have a library a
client library for oauth that can
make all of these requests right that
knows how to do the front channel thing
that knows how to harvest the act the
the code that knows how to turn the code
into a token all of that should not be
your job it should be the job of the
programming framework you're using and
and again i can only really speak um to
ace peanut core and they have a
brilliant client library it it is very
good we worked on it for a long long
time
but it's it is very good
then you have session management right
again a typical web application will
have a session meaning uh the broad the
user logs in and it will be valid for
one hour five hours sliding expiration
maybe a week you know
up to your
um
to your business case that is typically
done with cookies because we're in the
browser then we have some token
management going on right and that is
all about keeping the access token
keeping the refresh token using the
access token once it's expired use the
refresh token to create a new it get a
new access token and keep going okay um
this part here is unfortunately not
inside of a spirit core but i i've
written a client um
i i've written the library for that
which plugs into a speedcore and i think
i have a link to that in a minute that
helps you with all of that boilerplate
code and then you have ui assets right
um and it really doesn't matter to me
what kind of ui it is is it razer pages
is it mdc is it react or angular
whatever it's all the same
right they are browser-based
applications
actually if you want to know much more
about this i'm doing a talk after the
um
lunch break about that particular
architecture and how to get it right for
sparse and blazer web assemblies because
that is still
not as easy as it should be
good
if you are not in the browser guess what
you need a browser
yeah um
the benefit of native native
applications is is that they don't have
to rely on the browser for the whole
application lifetime right they just
open the browser for authentication
purposes they point to the authorized
request they get back the code and then
do
an hp call but the authentication
process should be run in a browser
yeah um
not everyone agrees with me on that
but it's definitely an anti-pattern
these days to bring up your own native
authentication dialogues in mobile apps
right you're sending out the wrong
signals here you should send the user to
the trusted authorization server on the
trusted hardware where you have all your
logging and and
auditing and fraud detection and
whatever you have on that server that's
where the user should log in and nowhere
else
okay
again remember what was the starting
point here
not make the user expose credentials to
a third party
right and even if the mobile app is
first party you are sending the wrong
signals to the user that this is okay
it's not
right
studies show the less often you make a
user sign into your system by having a
good single sign-on solution the less
prone they are to phishing attacks
right because the less often you have to
type in your path but maybe the more you
think about it when you have to
yeah so yeah there's a chance to make
stuff more secure just by
guiding the user
and not taking shortcuts
good
so
the last thing i want to touch on
in the last eight minutes
is um
you often maybe heard the sentence yeah
but oh it's not user authentication and
you're right it is not oauth was
designed to solve this one simple
problem how can a client application get
an access token to access an api
authentication
is an implementation detail
right
from an oauth point of view
authentication is out of scope yeah no
pun intended i guess um
so
to make o of more useful
um to authentication there are a couple
of things missing so look at that that's
how our authentication workflow works
right on the front channel we go here we
go back get a code the code is just a
random number on the back channel we go
here uh get a get an access token are we
allowed to look at the access token no
we are not so from a client's point of
view you might now have an access token
but you don't know who the user is
right
but that's where open id connect comes
in openly connect is an authentication
protocol on top that adds these things
for example maybe on the way on the
front channel you want to influence the
authentication experience for the user
by saying like hey maybe you should show
him the login page in portuguese or in
german or whatever right all of these
parameters to influence the
authentication experience they don't
exist in oauth because it wasn't
designed for that right um
on the back channel there should be some
data flowing back here that the client
is allowed to consume to figure out hey
dominic logged in
right
um and by the way he locked in with uh
multi-factor authentication and his
session is uh two hours old are you okay
with all of this before you let him into
your application right all of that stuff
does not exist in oauth and that's where
open id connect comes in by basically
introducing all of these things yeah
like additional parameters on the
authorized request to influence the
workflow and additional data on the
token response that the client can pass
in the standard format to make more
informed decisions about the user who
just logged in
okay
so
they call it the identity token which is
really a bad name for it because it has
the word token in it and it people are
sometimes confused now okay we have
access token refresh token identity
token which one do i use now
and the point is um if you are here in
my talk
yeah
whenever you hear the word identity
token
yeah translate it in your head with
authentication response it's it's the
data that the authorization server sends
back to the client to let the client
know what happened on the server
right that's a typical identity token
here yeah so that is flowing back to the
client and it says like hey subject id
is this name is alice
login time was that authentication
method was a password
yeah and where does that data flow back
on the back channel
okay so the front channel just works the
same but when the client exchanges the
code with the
with the
token they get back the access token to
call the apis and they get back the id
token which then
they pass validate the signature pass it
and then can say hello dominic in the ui
because we know who you are and before
that they didn't know because the access
token is out of bounds for the client
okay
cool
so that's it
you are now all
of experts
but that's really all i mean you know
for
um
if you are
more like a business developer right
that's all you need to know how it works
if you are more of a security developer
then this is a good starting point
okay
but yeah there are some interesting
documents that you might want to read
first of all is the o of 2.1 spec um
you know reading specs is not
everybody's favorite thing to do but i
can tell you it's it's useful
um here's the open open at the connect
spec and here you can see how open open
id connect layers on top of oauth to add
these additional features
um
here's a blog post i wrote a couple of
years ago actually where it says like
hey
all you need to remember is there are
two flows in oauth forget the rest okay
if anyone likes stellar soul
um
and some some other stuff okay
so that's it
um oh yeah and if you want to go like
really
into the weeds
then you can start reading all the specs
on these pages here where the source of
truth is coming from that is what i do
many times
cool
thank you that was it
um do you have any questions we have
like three more minutes before we close
yep
uh what
oh you know the itf moves slowly
um in 2020 i said it's going to be ready
this year
in 2021 i said it's going to be ready
this year i'm sure
this year i would say i think it's going
to be ready this
year um but
they are indeed in the last stages right
so the itf is a very democratic process
right you bring people into a room and
they can vote on stuff and if somebody
disagrees they have to discuss it you
know like all the wrong things about
democracy
um so yeah
it's it's totally fine to reading it now
because i think if something will change
it will be minor
and how you can prove to your colleagues
that you are even a bigger geek than
just reading specs you can read the
diffs between the versions of the stack
and know exactly what has changed
between revision 13 and revision 14.
okay so yeah no it's fine it's almost
done nothing fundamental will change
that is the record don't read the
original spec don't because that is just
not useful read this one oh it's gone
read read this one here the other one
i think that's the best the best source
okay
no
[Laughter]
the access token is for accessing apis
the identity token is a json object that
tells the client application who the
user is plus some added data which
happens to be a json web token
okay it's just a way to get this json
object from server back to client
without you know with a signature so it
can't be tampered with
typically the id token is a thing you
only consume once you read it
you want it's valid and then you throw
it away
no
by the with the authorization code
the talk is being recorded
if you want to watch it again and again
it's yeah the authorization code gives
you the id token and the access token
and that that's it really
yep
good
thank you very much
be around
you